welcome to this video play a plus came
and I am here from Russia and let's see
okay limbs are probably yeah playing the
same Michigan I really should vary a bit
them but yeah it it almost invariably
leads to interesting positions Wow
always amazed how often you get this
this kind of setup where bloggers are
known to be an in really bad shape and
against international master that set so
it sits around yeah that's basically
basically winning for white already if
you play it well okay I'm some night f5
or what is the best way to play you know
probably night at five the Queen g-form
even night g 7 as a threat iam it's just
the show's attack 96 yeah okay let's see
um 96 played simple on and then f5
yeah the tricky is part about this is
that there are so many promising
position position continuations that you
sometimes have a hard time to decide
what we want to play action it okay I'm
doing that with itself it's really a big
big choice p.m. Bishop takes you have
your cell so let's see you Mel h6 is not
too convincing I rather rather push the
push the effort on f5 f6
yeah it's not easy to say if this was
the the best possible way to attack but
it's it's it's dangerous maybe queen bee
6cm actually bishop is 395 hmm maybe
and
so I this wasn't great of this limb
because I really should have thought a
bit longer about this to really kill
this and now it's not so not so clear at
all
ah what a shame unbelievable yeah it's
always it's always a bit frustrating of
people play really am almost complete a
completely losing line which is very
well known for ages and and then you
you're not men you're not managing to
put it away it's just it's just bad play
rhyme you
I came here we've got multiple ways to
win no rookie for you will give a 4-h
form
their drive if to know what what tech
white resigns sure yeah well this is
just this is just unbelievably bad Black
is just lost here it's just a matter of
form of killing it off cleanly and I
didn't do it simply okay this is
probably enough but I need to I need to
play better here around here but it's
always frustrating if you if you look at
it with a computer maybe i can i can
even take on g7 prolly I mean isn't this
just just just winning yeah I even that
is winning plus two it's just just far
too much and this yeah knowing this this
is not so clear age 496 is also winning
here
here's something else I don't know it
takes and here I need to be I need to be
more precise this this counter play with
taking on c3 and Queen B 6 is just
strong here they're handy I mean the
winds earlier were much clearer of
course but here you need to need to kill
it off and this is probably do you need
just some precision here still and it's
still good I mean the position is so bad
for black that you can can afford some
stuff you should be three here yeah
especially just being a bit a bit more
cautious and I still have that check
coming f5 yeah even that is Kelly d
better if you will leave the comp eville
uation while this is just losing yeah f5
is the serve it's normal looking but
Queen B 6 I just should stop a moment
here I'd see that after Queen B 6 this
is also the problem that if I this
hanging and after that I'm just lost you
can enhance multiple ways to win here
rookie for as mentioned is the easiest
but you didn't do well it's not it's not
really measuring everything everything
is winning here for black and it's it's
easy just push the pawns yeah okay it
sometimes you should relax to already
even if the opponent place a completely
a completely losing opening you still
need to need to punish that I didn't
sometimes have a problem that i take too
long time and figure out the best best
way to play and then the time is lacking
at the end this wire try to play it a
bit a bit quicker yeah but it's may be
here I should have played like I usually
do
think a bit longer and really make sure
he did he doesn't see move 25 in this
game which would surely happen in a
tournament game for example to simply
simply unplayable this is opening
especially putting the bishop on a six
all right thanks for watching